ti aspettavi per farlo ho perso la voce
però non so come fai tu mike a tenerla
ancora tutti i piani di youtube facendo
però anche i ragazzi non è che fosse
proprio il primo più la smr del mondo
però vabbè ben voluto mike grazie grazie
grazie posso farlo io la dò entro vai
vai tu fai tutto bella tutti le galassie
sono le lettere questo melissa perché
fattura soldati è un milione e ragione
vegeta bellissimo siamo tornati su for
guys season fai la nuova stagione
ragazzi sono con il buon mike perché
siamo insieme perché è una ciotola che
ci vogliamo bene e basta o decidono bene
cosa te basta infatti fare video per
amica perché anche dobbiamo far torneo
domenica uscirà ragazzi il torneo dove
dobbiamo primeggiare dobbiamo portare
l'italia vince di nuovo dopo gli europei
dopo gli errori john cho europol guys
non facciamo i che vinciamo il torneo
almeno un italiano deve vincere quindi
siamo qua per allenarci se mai è un
prontissimo però posso aggiungere un po
di maiali veri pepe a questa società se
questo video supererà cento
mi piaceva vj il giorno del torneo
stream era e giocherà con un cappello da
banana
ok rispetto perché anch'io lo trovo un
cappello la banana sono col costume dal
bar i soli rai per meno male che vuole
raggiungere uguale sono contento di
raggiungere i mi piace vai ripartiamo
vuoi con to the jungle ragazzo faremo
poi le modalità che sono quella che ti
fa vedere le mappe nuove della season
che sono appunto c'è questo tema della
giungla dove faremo appunto di tarzan e
poi ce n'è una due e poi vediamo insomma
veniamo matri top tumble io lo fa però
grandi mike non ho fatto ancora noi in
questa sera non solo per questo che di
testa e questo è il video va bene
il video tira la tirata l'ha tirata
questa va beh almeno sul mio video a
ragazzi era cioè sembrava il
programmatore cioè la vallata sviluppato
lui perché la tua adesso filo di gusto
adesso che kakà tettino allora che amici
sosterà nei che esplodono è un po
complicato a stampa però siamo fiduciosi
dai e vai io già sto giu ma è bene che
mi piace volare capito che mi piace con
aria bello se si è uno a questa passione
un po il mio mio player ok ma hanno
lasciato dopo il dietro c'è stata io
sono primo per adesso non si vede dove
l'ho detto ragazzi incredibile perché
quando gli hanno detto guarda torneo
50.000 dollari e allora abbiamo sentito
il profumo di leno al sito impazzita ho
detto guarda
no non riesco a farlo sta roba nei così
che dondolano che fastidio non riesco a
farla mai perché ci sono sempre ci sono
ci sono e ci sono poche se questo accade
anno non ero prima o poi con ok andato
giù o no bisogna fronte secondo cacchio
il rinoceronte si è
insomma allora tedeschi madonna che ha
fatto un pelo coordinamento aspettando
aspettando qua ti puoi più fare
sull'altro cosa direttamente se vuoi va
beh sì sì sì è vero è vero è vero ma
faccio mai
sono caduto dai o poi lo posso far
capitare ma mi fai un infarto tra
l'altro nel tuo video mi è successa una
roba che adesso non sta succedendo ogni
tanto la mia skin si trasforma in che
cosa diamo un gas si trasforma nel
impostore ma lo manca loro e non ho
capito son bug o no lo sai te lo dico io
che forse è praticamente un easter egg è
un ricordarci quella volta che ti
elimina i sua monga
forse era meglio se lo ricordava potevi
come avvertire il momento in cui gli si
spezzava il cuore al caso da quella nave
era bello via ragazzi mib momenti però
di tanto ti tradisce buongiorno quel
giorno stavo particolarmente avevo fatto
ma già mi stanno fregando tutte sotto il
naso poi qualificato cosa si sta
aspettando una le scrivo by pass
e già che siamo in semifinale non è male
adesso uscirà fammi predire pinguini
fare quello con i rinoceronti quelle
bello anche quello ci starebbe vediamo
esatto mamma mia ma se indigenti ebbene
vengono al futuro l'indovino che sta
davanti sei tu quello esatto quello che
quello che adesso esatto questo ragazzi
sembra facile proprio market one che si
vola ma non tipo martin garics 130 si
vola proprio nel senso che questi qua
sembrano facili da fare ma da schivare
must i rinoceronti maledetti e incornano
proprio sì quindi non lo so ragazzi so
vediamo è spettato la tripla di tutti
bisognerebbe sta lì dietro arriva o no a
donna senza fare attenzione ma tornerò
ad un tac a grato se girato perché io
sto fa la tecnica del del camaleonte
eccola qua non ci
8 bis o io non posso farla finale in
speziato è vero è possibile se i
maledetti questo gioco mamma mia
la maledizione di casa ho visto
incornare proprio malissimo ragazzo
cesta peccato quando arrivano le corna
che poi era la finale cacchio ecco la
prima di arrivare le corna è sempre un
problema è giusto è giusto ragazzi
escono sempre no veramente sono usciti
in tanti che non li vedi quando escono
prima o poi per la legge dei grandi
numeri si vince prima o poi se tutti gli
altri si ferma lost è tempo di montain
fatta un po più da di avere un po più di
culo perché devi entrare nelle porte con
la testa e sperare che si sfondino
adesso vi faccio vedere parla sono
abbastanza fiducioso che questa la vinci
tu guarda subito 50 per cento è perfetto
non è male questo pezzo quarta fila per
cavo sede vita no no va bene va bene va
bene va bene adesso primo soli ma va
bene va bene che questa per forza sono
nati ampio ma questa giusta dritta
dritta tricamo sento ma trova sempre
tricolo sempre dritto non è vero
va bene va bene va bene va bene ma desta
per forza testa per forza no no no ti
sei incastrato va bene va bene per le
riprese lei brasile ripresi ecco però
intenzione tu e tua mamma mia è la prima
volta che qualcuno dice ma questa la
sento che la vinci e la vincono adesso
nella storia di paul guys né di questo
gioco quindi craxi e mike per guai
portata veramente grazie a ciò che
quelle nove le abbiamo fatte facciamo
un'altra roba
a prevedere se riesce
lersquo voglio vedere come bajdechi
vediamo è sì non so non ho capito come
funziona doveva arrivare tutti e due
sostanzialmente sono almeno non ci fa
dire no no no no vuoi andare c'è poi
anche
squadra scora attenzione guarda
periferiche strano perché no i primi 20
si qualificano odio non l'ho mai fatto
che stessa società che non si capisce ma
credo che sia tipo si arrivi tu e
comunque ci siamo qualificati è stato
preso presenza poi tela maniera
incredibile non sa come capirci per noi
vinci per noi vinci per noi va bene
aspetta ci provo
sono settimo ma va bene va bene
nono decimo ecco dai 48 punti ai appunti
c'è noi accumuliamo punti nelle
parlamento è capito perché vedi che
elimina le squadre
oddio quindi le prime venti quindi non
ho ben capito se adesso ricette al
punteggio oppure se si va a sommare
quelli di prima perché se no credo che
la partita
no credo che alle 7 e non lo so vediamo
speriamo così perché hanno sempre di
topi nutriti questa roba tua questa roba
tua purtroppo i ragazzi sono che subisce
la pressione quando il gioco si fa duro
va bene anche e soprattutto come
eliminato sulla mongai vabbè non lo
ritiro questa norma i ragazzi gli
rinfaccia a vita non bisognava ok ben
noto poi sono caduto anche io ma niente
niente tutelerà tutto quello che può
andare storto mi sta andando storto vuol
cambiato gioco al day 4 tasti permanenti
ok ok ci sono 76 avanti sarà di tutti
niente tutto quello che può andare
storto ci sono dicono no ok ok sesto
se no sono scivolato decimo ma per aveva
veramente bene sorpa dai dai dai che non
è male sensi
non è malissimo non è malissimo scusa ma
la finale come farai a punti anche
quella stanzialmente veloce dice eh sì
forse dobbiamo arrivare a gravare la
corona e chi la grappa pinto la squadra
a norma non è appunto quella promessa
non lo so secondo me a questo a questo
punto di vista ci sono anche tanti che
nel senso che uno dei tre potrebbe
tenere fermi gli altri non lo so però
dico si studieranno per tutte le tanti
problemi vari try harder avesse finale
non ho visto che si guarda
no no non è finale pazzesco allora bike
ne prego ti prego ti prego non c'è gente
c'è stato in 14 dai dai fatti sempre il
migliore 14 di paul guys proprio dai
sono degli infami se ci mettono
all'ultima fila ed ai semi in 14 ci
siamo tutti in prima fila io vado sei
fregato 6 forse in casi va bene se
infatti va bene ma ultimo ultimo anch'io
ho anche io perché temo stronzi cosa vi
devo dire che va dai perché cile mettere
ultimi siamo in pochi
ci stiamo tutti in prima fila
ok ok 66 si ok ci sono ci sono arrivati
a 9 scivola il mio cielo chanteclaire
chantecler va bene non importa il primo
no ma se primo bavaj signor fa vj vada
vada non cincischi non cincischia non
cincischia primo no ma secondo
tra i primi ok anno prima se devo primo
prima notizie
faccio questo non ha mai sbagliato ok
perfetto suo primissimo dài e dài e dài
mai siamo criticati perché cosa buttati
su cosa è questa se arrivati i primi sul
serio rimanenti cinque squadre va bene
adesso ci fanno fare cosa de corones
mamma mia come funziona qua punteggio
sempre se potrebbe essere a punteggio
anche questa in realtà allora io me ne
vado a destra di beni che non è una
punteggio quindi vince come si fa a
vincere poi per la voleva tanto cosa
state due ore perché quando si allinea
di minuti non esistono estate i due
minuti e pasquetta
dov'è che è il simbolo grosso che che
c'è sempre al tuo amico questo lo devono
mettere sempre quando c'è qualcuno in
parti maledizione che non capisco è ok
ok ok io sono questo qui è uno
all'eliminato ok linea t2 attenzione e
adesso comincio ad essere un po
importante adesso comincia a essere
adesso si è stato a quando la partita
perché adesso inizia a essere minata la
gente quindi attenzione
eccoci perfetto buono buono come sta
andando mai e so se trovati un punto una
zona di confort pietro è un po difficile
perché no mi ha buttato giù non ci credo
mamma mamma mia mi ha spinto ma non va a
punteggio no no no questo è
chi vince e allora conseguito di qui
d'occhio che ti sta bene ti sta venendo
addosso al bravo e tu e tua questa zona
è tua e che la povera e girata da una
donna rischio no no no no ok ma vogliamo
anche se sì pure quello che doppio
occhio anni di questo che doppio stylist
a il libro bravo parole avesse rimane
bravo ormai ragazzi oggi sta in modalità
rivals bravissimo un più alto
bravissimo doppio salto ancora c'è in
finale il finale piccolo marcio shah
wali j pronti per gli europei ma dove ha
fatto anche la rima incredibile ma
pronti per il torneo è traditore o nei
ragazzi per questo video incredibile
questo evidente video pazzesco ragazzi
200.000 laico 800mila che ne so
bellissimo ma si vada a doppia vittoria
io io ti voglio vedere vestito la banana
vende insomma si scherzava ragazzi non
mettetela yc allora io ringrazio il buon
mike però che mi ha accompagnato sia nel
jungle che nel duo che abbiano a male
grazie a voi ragazzi grazie a te perché
magari a torino infatti arrestato in
creare con succede spesso sta roba
incredibile però il rifiuto passate
anche la cani mike che abbiamo fatto un
video né sul folk hizb al sito 5
allenamento il torneo anche il suo
canale mini passate ragazzi io vi saluto
e vi ringrazio aver subito video mi
raccomando domenica tutti a seguire il
torneo perché sarà insomma memorabile
speriamo non lo so poi fare un kacar e
non solo noi a 20 euro
spero spero di no ci siamo ragazzi
quando ho lasciato un bel commento mi
piace iscritti al canale era ci diamo
allora
[Musica]